let's talk about megido all the Uproar
about megido all the
Uproar about megido all right even our
boy Cameron bartuzi did something on
megiddo all right let's look at
it guess what folks this is not new in
the heart of this is
old this is not new folks this is old
news folks the megiddo extion
is megido inscription is old it may be
new to you you know who mentioned it way
back way back I want to show it to you
in a debate James
White why do you guys think the megiddo
inscription is
new who told you I was aware of this
ages ago when James White was in London
and he debated Sami zri on whether
Christ is the Divine Son of God or a
Muslim Prophet this is not new folks so
it's like kind of amusing to
see that people are now mentioning it
making a big deal out of it when it's
been known for years let me show you now
I'm going to show you where James White
mentions the megiddo inscription as
archaeological proof for the widespread
early worship of Jesus Christ as God In
the
Flesh let me show it to you now I'm
going to tell you where to go watch his
debate but the one that's on the Muslim
site they show his screen where he has
images of the M megido inscription let's
go here here it
is now I'm going
to play it from the Christian Muslim
debate but here is where you can watch
this debate
the grouo marks of Islamic apologetics
whom by the power of the trium god power
Lord Jesus Christ we sent to retirement
he's gone you won't hear of him anymore
but here it is
begins right here and I'm gonna give you
the
date here it is watch it from you can
watch it
here Alpha and Omega Ministries make
this goar instead of the Muslim Channel
notice when it
was November 11
2008 November 11 2008 you see the
date you see it right here for the rest
of you on Raga make rumble great
again now watch November
11 2008 James White mentions the megido
inscription what
date November 11 2008 you see
it now watch I'm going to go to the
other one because you see the images
let's go to the other
one right
here let me give you this way you know
but anyway watch James White mentioned
the megiddo inscription
all the way back
then so you guys think it's new it's not
new it's been around folks now watch
James White mention it as some the extra
biblical historical archaeological proof
for the widespread worship and devotion
Jesus Christ as God okay you ready let's
play it 1 hour 58 second Mark let's go
here watch here let's go a little
earlier watch on the screen you're going
to see it Sammy said well calling Son of
God do mean your god well ask the Jews
in John 19 the Jews answered him we have
a law and by that law he ought to die
because he made himself out to be the
sonate go back I think James White
schooled him but Sammy was too stupid to
realize he got schooled go watch it
excellent
debate what was the death used for used
for a number of things behold be the
only one that would be relevant to claim
to be the Son of God
BL BL that's how the Jews understood it
John 5 John 19 cannot be overthrown that
is the definition provided by the text
itself now some might say well look now
extra biblical historical archaeological
proof for the widespread worship
devotions of Jesus Christ as God watch
listen this is just all later invention
this is all came along later
I'd like to read you some the early
Christian writings for example Ignatius
the bishop of Antioch writing ad 107 817
is very early there is one physici of
Flesh and of spirit generate and
ingenerate God and man true life and
death both from Mary and from God first
passible and impassible Jesus Christ Our
Lord that's my christology in the first
generation after the apostles watch here
writing to polycarp the same writer says
to the Ephesians by the will of the
father and of Jesus Jesus Christ Our God
or for our God Jesus the Christ in his
epistle to Ephesians writing polycarp
await the one who is above every season
the Eternal the invisible the one who
for our sake became visible the
untouched the impassible who for our
sake suffered who endured in every way
for our sake this has been Bel Christian
from the beginning you want further
Evidence how about some archaological
evidence here is a picture from 2005
they were redoing a prison in megiddo
did hear it James White beat you guys to
it 2008 debate London he mentions the
megido inscription found in
2005 God
loving is it acus whatever's name is to
God Jesus Christ this is old news
folks you hear now watch
listen and they found one the earliest
Christian churches ever found you see it
he even brought an image to the
debate you see it this was in 2008 he
already beat you guys to it so everyone
is talking about the megiddo inscription
who told you it's new it's been known
for years folks and when it came up I go
you know what I'm gonna now show people
this is old news I became aware of it
back then when I watched James White's
debate this is why you can learn from
even your enemies those who are enemies
of the faith what do I say chew the meat
spit out the bones don't thr the baby
with the bath water right separate me
from it learn from him on these areas
you
agree learn right there look what he's
going to
say all right and I'm gonna play another
version that's even more
what do I say uh what's the word I'm
looking for anyway I don't know the word
I'm looking for forget about it from the
second century and here's a picture of
Mosaic on the ground here's another
angle of that same Mosaic and here's
that Mosaic so he even gives you the
words in
Greek right here Boom the images beat
you to it folks a little up close here
that's what it says I'll give you the
translation the God loving Aus has
offered this table as Memorial to our
God Jesus J you see it our God Jesus
Christ we have AR theological evidence
it is very now some might say well this
is just all right polycarp await the one
who is above every season Eternal the
invisible the one who for our sake
became visible the untouched the
impassible who for our sake suffered who
endured in every way for our sake this
has been the belief of the Christian
people from the beginning you want
further Evidence how about some
archeological evidence here is a picture
from 2005 they were redoing a prison in
megiddo and they found one of the
earliest Christian churches ever found
from the second century and here's a
picture of the Mosaic on on the ground
here's another angle of that same Mosaic
and here's that Mosaic little up close
here that's what it says I'll give you
the translation the God loving the God
loving Aus has offered this table as a
memorial to our God Jesus Christ and
here it is
this is the nomina sakra n Sak where
they abbreviate names of deity and
things associate with deity
right there you go beat you to it
guys beat you to
itus has offered this table as Memorial
to our God Jesus Christ there you go now
let's go listen to the other version
that's a little clearer you guys okay
with this old news
folks so who told you it's new folks
let's go here because the other one the
sound is better then we're going to go
into it you guys are right you're
hanging with me right you're not getting
bored with this I gave you links go
watch it was excellent debate he did an
excellent job I can't lie he did an
excellent job now let's go to this
version which begin see the Alpha and
Omega version is better cleaner sound
quality is
better and let me get you the link again
we're gonna go now in this version it's
at the 55 minute 25 second Mark H this
cat needs
attention so there you
go you guys enjoying this so far now
let's go 55 minute 28 second Mark he
already beat you to it man 2008 what why
do you guys think it's new
because people don't do in-depth
research study in ancient artifacts
that's okay I'm not condemning you for
it but here let's start here sake
suffered who endured in every way for
our sake this has been the belief of the
Christian people from the beginning you
want further Evidence how about some
archaeological evidence here is a
picture from 2005 they were redoing a
prison in megiddo and they found one of
the earliest Christian churches ever
found from the second century and here's
a picture of a mosaic on the on the
ground here's another angle of that same
Mosaic and here's that Mosaic uh little
up close here that's what it says I'll
give you the translation the God loving
Aus has offered this table as Memorial
to our God Jesus Christ there you go so
who told you the megiddo
inscription is
new it's not 2005 and James White was
already using it in his debates we have
literary evidence we have archaeological
evidence it is very very very
clear that when you go to the first
century documents that's what comes with
the first 100 years after Jesus they all
testify to a belief in the deity of
Christ massive overwhelming evidence so
there you go